theo công van của cuộc quan li và phát triển thì chuân trong nước, người sợ công thường cá tình thành phố.
Chứ như bình đồng của tình khi chiến chiến anh đến của tế,
tắt động đến của một công và giản lượng và cầu.
Thì trường xong rầu đặc biệt là mặt hàng rầu để ô đang chữ nhiều ap lực.
Bộ công thường đến nghĩa cái địa phương, tăng cường giảm xác tị trường,
nằm chắc tình khi cũng cầu, lượng tổn khó và giảm ạ tức tế tại các cửa bà lẻ.
Lâm thời kip thời phát hiện, sự li khải bị vi phạm, gì là gấm hàng, bà nhanh cầm trường,
tự ý giúp ngắn thời gian kinh jóan, khoảng nương banh hàng khi chưa được cơ quan có thập quyền xác tốt.
Bình cạnh đó các thương nhân đồng mối, thương nhân phần phối và hệ thống cửa hảm bản lẻ xong rầu,
được yêu cầu chủ đậu muôn hàng, thực hiện nghiêm cầm kết bảo đảm của công,
vui chỉ hảm đậu banh hàng li tục.
Bộ công thường của yêu cầu tất cả các cửa hảm bản lẻ xong rầu,
mơ cửa đúng thời gian đã đăng kỹ,
niềm ít giả để đủ và bán đúng giả niềm ít,
gó phần ông định kỹ trường và bảo đảm quyền lợi quón người tư dông.